[Music]  [Applause]  who is she  [Music]  we went worldwide to look for  our maya lopez and we really wanted to  stay true to the characters in the  comics  [Music]  maybe i rip out your throat or maybe she  will  [Applause]  [Music]  she's brand new to this whole thing  something that happens with some actors  that when they step in front of the  camera there was this kind of like  collective inhale of breath and  everyone's like  she's just got this star quality to her  laqua is amazing she's really just wide  open emotionally and and was able to  contribute a lot she's a natural  he's an amazing character to have set up  and with the new actress like alaqua is  that's been such a gift for us  [Applause]  [Music]  you